[Musique]
brute de belleville dont on ne peut
parler qu'à moitié puisqu'elle joue à
saute moutons entre deux arrondissements
on vous montre tout de même son vieux
funiculaire on a le droit edd au milieu
e
et tout en haut de belleville au début
de la rue on a non
par maurice chevalier
mais la rue la plus étroite de paris on
ne peut y passer à deux de front
elle s'appelle aller des pêcheurs voici
la face cachée du 19e arrondissement
celle pour laquelle il existe des
amoureux du 19e celle qui fait rêver
tous les provinciaux de paris
celle qui transporte dans un autre monde
le monde de la campagne perdue
au temps où paris trail est ses chèvres
faisait paître ses vaches ou de ces
collines elle se réveillait au chant du
coq
[Musique]
le temps disparu les rues s'appelait
villa et où l'on empruntait leurs noms
n'ont pas à des victoires ou à des
généraux mais à dépeindre des baux ait
des musiciens
lieu privilégié où l'otan est établie au
fond des escaliers de pierre accrochée
aux grilles de fer forcé flottant au
fond des cours où il existe encore des
surprises
[Musique]